Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Emre Göchtas.
Bevor wir anfangen,
mein Name ist Emre Göchtas.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen,
lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst
Ihren persönischen Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid
oder fragen Sie nach.
Okay?
Ja klar.
Okay. Erst mal,
wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Dr. Jürgen Lausin.
Guten Lausin.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren
Vor- und Nachnamen nochstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist
Jürgen, J-U,
also U-Umlaut,
L-G-E-N.
Okay.
Nachnamen?
Und der Familienname
ist Lausin, L-A-U.
S-I-E-N.
Herr Dr. Lausin,
wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie mir bitte
Ihr Geburstab?
Ja, das ist der 13. Februar 43.
43.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m.
76?
Wie viel wegen
Sie?
84 kg wiegt ich.
84 kg.
Okay.
Herr Dr. Lausin,
sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwidert schon lange.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe 3 Erwachsene-Kinderjahr.
Was machen Sie?
Ich glaube, ich sind Sie schon
Rentner.
Ich bin ein paar Jahre näher.
Ich war in der
Hochschullehrer.
Ich habe Mathematik gelehrt.
Herr Dr. Lausin,
was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwester haben Sie?
Mein Hausarzt hat mich zu Ihnen geschickt.
Es ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ich meinen obersten Hemp-Knobs
gar nicht mehr richtig zubekomme.
Dann habe ich mal so nachgefühlt.
Dann habe ich gemerkt,
dass das hier so geschwollen ist
am Hals.
Das ist wirklich schön.
Das ist ein Schmerz.
Ich bin zum Arzt gegangen.
Als das nach ein paar Wochen nicht besser wurde.
Ich dachte, ich habe ein bisschen
Erkältung oder ein Infekt.
Ich habe geschwollene
Lymphknoten.
Als das nicht wegging,
bin ich zum Arzt gegangen.
Er hat mich zu Ihnen geschickt.
Ich habe diese Geschwolle
nicht mehr verwendet.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr verwendet.
Wie lange, wann genau,
haben Sie diese Geschwollene
Lymphknoten?
Das war bestimmt schon 6-8 Wochen.
Erst habe ich gedacht,
es geht von alleine wieder weg.
Was hat Ihr Hausarzt Ihnen gesagt?
Welche Medikamente haben Sie
Ihnen genug gegeben?
gegeben, sondern hat mich zu Ihnen geschickt. Okay. Okay, haben Sie Schluckbeschwerte?
Nicht so richtig doll, eigentlich nicht. Okay, Sie können die Bestennahlung und oder
Müßigkeit trinken und essen ohne... Ja, das macht nichts, ja. Aber ich habe nicht so richtig
Appetit zurzeit. Ich fühle mich nicht gut und bin ein bisschen schlapp und habe auch nicht so
richtig Appetit. Seit wann? Das ist auch seit der nächsten Umkunft. Nee, das ist noch nicht so lange.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht seit zwei, drei Wochen. Ja, tatsächlich habe ich ordentlich abgenommen,
ja. Ich habe fünf Kilo abgenommen in den letzten drei, vier Wochen und das mir auch zu schaffen
macht, ich schlafe nach so schlecht, weil ich so schwitze. Ich muss manchmal nach Zwischendurch
mein Schlaferanzug ausziehen und dann muss ich mir etwas Neues anziehen.
Ich habe jetzt gemessen, neulich hatte ich mal 38 und ich muss von der Telefon aufgelangen.
So, sorry. Wir haben diese Temperatur gemessen. Und am Arm. Ist Ihnen noch
irgendwelche Schwellung ein aufgefallen? Ich meine außer Hals. Nee, sonst habe ich das,
nur aber ich wäre auch nicht drauf gekommen, danach zu gucken. Das bin ich aufgefallen.
Okay, bei der Körperkontrolle können wir gerne natürlich untersuchen. Oder haben
Sie Druckgefühl im Bauch? Ja, mal was habe ich?
Ein Druckgefühl im Bauch? Ne, habe ich eigentlich nicht. Ich meine, ich bin so ein bisschen
verstopft. Dann habe ich vielleicht so ein Druckgefühl im Bauch, aber dann nehme ich
immer Movilicol und dann geht es wieder besser. Das nehme ich dann, wenn ich das brauche.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Atmen? Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, oder haben Sie Lusten? Nee, auch kein Lusten. Also wie das Einzige ist,
dass ich eben ein bisschen Fieber habe, dass ich nachts nicht gut schlafen kann und dass ich so
schlapp und appetitlos bin und mich eigentlich selber nicht wiedererkennend bin.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona? Ich bin komplett geimpft. Ja, in meinem Alter wurde
man ja frühzeitig geimpft. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit zum Ausland gereist?
Nein, in meinem Alter fahre ich nicht mehr viel in der Gegengrund. Nein.
Okay, Frau Dr. Lausen, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen? Ja, was heißt chronische Erkrankungen?
Also ich habe ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfeldwerte. Das hat man mal festgestellt.
Und ich habe so eine chronische Binderhaut-Einzündung. Deswegen muss ich
überregelmäßig Augen tropfen nehmen und nehme ich eigentlich zur Sicherheit seit fünf Jahren,
glaube ich schon, nehme ich Pantoprazol. Das hat man mir mal verschrieben,
als ich Bauchschmerzen hatte. Aber sonst nehme ich eigentlich, naja, gut, wenn ich Rhythmischmerzen
habe, dann nehme ich natürlich Ibo. Seit wann haben die erhöhte Blutfeldwerte?
Oh, das ist bestimmt schon 20 Jahre, würde ich sagen.
Wogegen nehmen Sie Pantoprazol? Ja, ich hatte mal so eine Bauchschmerzengeschichte.
Und weil ich ziemlich regelmäßig wegen der Rhythmischmerzen Ibo-Prophen nehme,
hat mir der Hausarzt dann Pantoprazol gegeben.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden? Nee, operiert worden bin ich noch nicht.
Haben Sie wichtige Vorallkranken gehabt?
Nein, nur das, was ich gesagt habe. Also die Blutfeldwerte, aber sonst bin ich immer gesund gewesen.
Okay, gut. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige, menselische Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen wollte?
Ja, also meine Schwester hatte einen Schlafferanfall, die ist halbseitig gelebt, mit 73, bis das passiert.
Und meine Eltern leben natürlich nicht mehr. Mein Vater hatte einen Kälekopfkrebs und ist da dran gestorben.
Der hat aber auch ordentlich geraucht und ordentlich Schnaps getoeren.
Und meine Mutter hatte tatsächlich eine Demenz.
Ich habe mir genau gesagt, schlafen Sie gut? Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, schwitzen Sie nachts viel?
Ja, ich schwitze nachts und ich muss oft mal auf die Toilette.
Haben Sie Probleme, einschlafen?
Nur zum Einschlafen, das klappt, aber ich wache halt immer ganz richtig und durch auf, wenn ich so nass geschwitzt bin oder eben wenn ich zur Toilette muss.
Ja, ja, da. Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Nur, dass ich so oft muss.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie seelisch belastet?
Ach, in meinem Alter, eigentlich bin ich zufrieden.
Das freut mich.
Hause Pantoprazol und Ibuprofen, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Sie haben gesagt, Pantoprazol und Ibuprofen, da sind wir Statin, nehm ich noch.
Und dann eben diese Augentropfen, die heißen Ofthalmenen.
Wie viele Gramm Statin nehmen Sie?
40, eine Abend.
Ibuprofen?
Ja, wenn es mir mit der Wirbelsäule, also ich habe so so Bandscheibenprobleme, wenn es da, wenn es da schlecht ist, nehme ich eine 600er, 3-mal am Tag.
Medikam Pantoprazol nehmen Sie?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, wenn ich mir gerade gar nicht sicher, was da draufsteht.
Nachher können wir Ihre Hausart, kann ich Ihre Hausart fragen, ja?
Ja, genau.
Raufen wie?
Ja, ich habe lange Zeit geraucht, aber habe das auch schon vor langer Zeit wieder aufgegeben.
Ich habe vor 18 Jahren, habe ich das Raufen aufgehört.
Da habe ich Fragen, wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
30 Jahre habe ich gut geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie täglich geraucht?
Ein Teckchen war das wohl, 20 waren das wohl, ja.
An einem Zeichen, okay.
20 Zigaretten, ne?
Mhm.
Schönen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also am Abend ein bis zwei Gläser Wein, das würde ich mir schon, ja.
Gleich mal.
Oh, mein Leben lang schon, seit ich erwachsen bin, seit ich mir das leisten kann, Wein zu trinken, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nie.
Da habe ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich eine lästige Allergie.
Ich esse eigentlich nämlich gerne Erdbeeren, aber das vertrage ich nicht.
Da kriege ich ein Hautausschlag.
Okay, Herr Dr. Lausing.
Meineseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ach, ich glaube, Sie haben wirklich so viele gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Jetzt bin ich natürlich nur neugierig, wie Sie mir helfen können und was dahinter steckt.
Herr Dr. Lausing, um die richtige Diagnose zu stellen, möchte ich möglichst viel Information über Ihnen sammeln.
Über Sie?
Über Sie sammeln.
Deswegen habe ich zu viel gefragt.
Aber erst einmal, leider kann ich Ihnen leider nichts genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Ich muss zuerst die weiteren Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Zuerst würde ich die Körpersche untersuchen.
Danach brauche ich Ihnen von Ihnen Blutabnahme.
Ich möchte auch diese Halsschwellung kontrollieren durch ultraskalbe Untersuchung.
Ja, das ist bestimmt gut.
Nach der Ergebnisse besprechen wir noch einmal.
Wenn wir weiter untersuchen, dann gebe ich Ihnen Bescheid und können wir zusammen darüber entscheiden.
Ja, super. Das klingt gut.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie im Mathezimmer Platz.
Danke schön.
Hat noch jemand dazu eine Frage?
Keine.
Ich würde auch sagen, das war ziemlich komplett.
Dr. Gündis, haben Sie noch etwas?
Keine Frage.
Keine Frage, ja.
Man merkt, dass Elbre hat schon echt eine Menge Alamnesen gemacht.
Ja, das war richtig gut.
Kanntest du den Fall?
Ich habe nicht.
Welcher Fall ist das?
Ja, ich habe mich schubbelt beim Namen.
Ich habe die Namen verändert, dass es nicht so einfach ist.
Gerade die Anose ist nicht klar bei mir.
Deswegen gucke ich die Information.
Okay.
Ja, wenn ich die Anose auf dem Schiff habe,
dann habe ich die Anose auf dem Schiff.
Ja, wenn ich keine Frage habe,
kann ich die vorstellung machen.
Ja, gerne.
Eine Moment.
Ja, klar.
Sonst, Gündis, wissen Sie die Diagnose?
Nicht verraten.
Aber wissen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Aber ist tatsächlich ein neuer Fall.
Ja, ich habe die Anose auf dem Schiff gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Kommt aus dem Mainzer-Fellepool.
Okay.
Kann ich anfangen?
Gut.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberärztin.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Ja.
Er ist 79 Jahre alt.
Er ist 176 cm groß.
Er klagt über Schmerzhafte.
Er hat味 Blindkeit.
Er wird umkündigt.
5 kg abgenommen und sein Appetit ist seit zwei, drei Wochen nicht gut und als weiterer Beschwerden nennt
er Okspiration, dagegen nehme er Movicolbeutel ein und der Vorerkrankung liegt Hyperlipidemis seit 20
Jahren, Koninktivitis und ein Bauchschmerz, Abdominalschmerzen, Rückenschmerzen vor, aber er weiß
genau nicht, was die Abdominalschmerzen sind und Rückenschmerz, Diskusprolaps. Gegen
Er hat Rückenschmerzen, weil er Diskusprolaps festgestellt wurde.
Der Familienanamnese liegt bei dem Vater Leidungskartner und bei der Mutter als Seimer und bei der Schwester Apoplex
vor. Er hat in der vegetative Anamnese gibt es Necturie und er nimmt regelmäßig Zimmaster
Kin 40 mg abends und bei Bedarf auf Timing Augen tropfen, getropft und er nimmt auch regelmäßig
Pantoprasol und bei Bedarf ich überprüfen sich 120 Gramm ein. Er habe bis vor 18 Jahren, 30
Jahre lang eine Pette am Tat geraucht und er trinkt abends ein, zwei Gläser Wein regelmäßig und er ist
allergiege gegen Erdschere und diese allergie ursächtlich mit Hausaufs
exanter. Ja wunderbar. Ja, was ist denn jetzt ihre Verdachtstiagnose? Nach den bisherigen
Angaben gehe ich von Leiningskartinon aus. Was könnte alternativ sein,
differential diagostisch? Differential diagostisch kommen zum Beispiel ein
Hochschildner Formel im Bett. Was hätten wir noch im Angebot, was könnte es noch sein?
Kann zum Beispiel ein Hypochlorid-Kartinon sein. Und etwas ösefabus, aber gegen
ösefabus-Kartinon sprechen, der Patient hat keine Schluckbeschwerde.
Ja, genau. Es ist tatsächlich hier als Differentialdiagose mit aufgeführt, aber
genau, dagegen spricht es, dass er keine Schluckbeschwerde hat. Das ist richtig.
Ja, was untersuchen Sie denn bei den Patienten jetzt?
Erstmal, natürlich, ich würde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Sorry, ich muss mir eben gleich unterbrechen. Erstmal, nicht ich würde, sondern würde ich
den Patienten körperlich untersuchen. Ich sage jetzt mal gleich. Ja, okay. Also erst mal würde ich
den Patienten körperlich untersuchen. Bei der Körperuntersuchung kann ich die
natürliche Pylpation, Pylpizierendereils, kann ich den Pylpizierendereils palpieren?
Ja, und ich möchte diese Lämpfknoten lokalisieren und bestimmen wie
die Schwellung ist. Danach brauchen wir operative Untersuchungen und die Labor
untersuchen. Ja, beim Labor, wonach gucken Sie? Beim Labor, ich möchte die Entzündung
Parameter kontrollieren und großes Blutbild brauchen und leber und Nierenwerte auch.
Und was noch? Und natürlich die Theroidgärte. Ja, genau, da habe ich noch drauf gewartet.
Genau. Und hier ist noch angegeben eine Serologie.
Serologie, CHP. Hier ist noch etwas anderes erwähnt. Ja, genau.
Epstein-Barr. Genau. Epstein-Barr und HIV ist hier noch erwähnt.
Okay. Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht mehr dran gedacht, aber ja.
Gut, was erwarten Sie denn im Blutbild?
Im Welcher, erdacht werfen, in welcher Diagnose, meinst du, im Ladingstationum.
Ja. Beispiel, der Patient hat, kann eine Anämie haben und er hat gerade Fieber,
können wir auch lökig, kurz groß. Okay. Gut. Und ja, möglicherweise zeigt sich ja auch noch was anderes
dann im Labor. Gut, Sie machen eine operative Untersuchung, was machen Sie da?
Beim operativen Untersuchung können wir ein Hals-Ustrationografie durchführen.
Und natürlich, wenn wir ein Verdacht auf Cardiom haben, brauchen wir ein CHP-Untersuchung
mit Kontrastmittel. Und ja. Brauchen wir für die, für die Metastasenzuche?
Genau. Ja, okay. Genau. Und wenn wir etwas Besonderes bemerken, dann können wir ein,
für die Paragraphopie. Ja. Ja, okay, gut.
Und ja, was wäre, wenn wir eine unauffällige Ladingstituation vorfinden?
Was wäre dann der nächste Verdacht? Wie würde man dann weiter gucken?
Ladingstrahl-Verdacht, Jan-Marc. Ne, wenn die Laryngoskopie oder wenn der Laryngsbefund
unauffällig ist. Okay. Was wäre dann?
Was gucken wir dann? Haben wir schon die differenzialen Diagnose gesagt, aber außer diese Diagnose?
Ja, in welcher Untersuchung machen Sie dann noch? Das meine ich.
Okay. Laryngoskopie unauffällig, CT unauffällig, Ultraschall unauffällig.
Ja, es ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht unauffällig. Also nur das Laryngskatzidum ist es nicht.
Aber andere Sachen können ja auffällig sein. Die Lymphknoten können zum Beispiel auffällig sein.
Was wäre da noch für eine Diagnose? Ja, genau, das ist der Punkt.
Lymphknotenbiopsy, genau. Ja, genau. Für die Hochschkin-Lymphoma.
Genau, genau.
Okay. Ja, gut. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, machen Sie doch mal Ihre Untersuchung
und erhalten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden. Was dabei rausgekommen ist, ich bin sehr gespannt,
welcher Verdacht sich nachher wirklich erhärtet. Und informieren Sie den Patienten natürlich auch über die anstehende Untersuchung.
Okay. Okay. Ja.
Tatsächlich ist es der Hochschkin gewesen. Ja, es war tatsächlich der Hochschkin.
Und das Laryngskatzidum war bei den Differenzialdiagnosen aufgeführt.
Und hier kommt es euch noch die Frage nach der Therapieoption.
Was für eine Therapie, wenn ein Hochschkin hat, tatsächlich, was ist die Therapie?
Therapie ist ein Hochschkin-Lymphoma. Es ist hängt.
Ich bin ja nicht sicher, genau, aber...
Zwei Sachen nur.
Radiotherapie? Einmal.
Radio und Chemo.
Chemo, ja.
Also, um das aufzuklären, es war eben tatsächlich der Hochschkin, wobei ich war wirklich davon ausgegangen,
dass der Hochschkin den jungen Männern vorbehalten ist. Aber es gibt tatsächlich, ich habe nochmal nachgelesen,
es gibt nochmal eine Spitze nach 70.
Und das wusste ich selber nicht. Ich hatte das immer so mit jungen Männern assoziiert.
Und daraufhin habe ich dann den Fall ein bisschen umgeschrieben.
Der war für eine Frau mit einem anderen Namen bei der Fall gemacht.
Wenn du nachguckst bei den Mainzer Fällen.
Aber sonst habe ich alles eins zu eins umgesetzt.
Ich habe besonders gefragt, wie andere geschwollene Körperteile und die Brutgefühl wegen Verdacht auf Hochschkin.
Mit der Milz.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber das ist ihm halt noch nicht aufgefallen.
Gut, aber war ja wirklich perfekt. Also ich würde sagen, das war in jeder Hinsicht sowohl die Anamnese als auch die Patientenvorstellung war richtig, richtig gut.
Und ich glaube auch, du musst wirklich überhaupt keine Sorge vor der Prüfung haben.
Du hast so viel Routine und machst das auch wirklich sehr, sehr schön.
Auch immer wieder die Ansprache des Patienten und so. Also richtig, richtig gut.
Gut. Bist du selber auch zufrieden heute Abend?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit habe ich ein bisschen Angst, weil ich...
Weil die Prüfung herrückt.
Nein, ich habe gedacht, ich bin immer zurückgehe. Deswegen ging. Aber jetzt heute ist gut, ja.
Aber ich muss ab und zu mal Anamnese erheben. Ja, klar. Sonst kommt man aus der Übung.
Das ist schon auch ein bisschen Training.
Gut, Dr. Gündüß.
Ja, vielen Dank für das Geschäft.
Frau Geheld.
Sie haben sehr viel Mühe gegeben und vielen, vielen Dank.
Gerne. Nein, ihr wisst ja alle, ich mache das gerne.
Und für heute haben wir aber, glaube ich, dann gut gearbeitet.
War es wirklich richtig gute Anamnesen, fand ich.
Und wir sehen uns wieder, heute ist schon Donnerstag, ne?
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag, ist das okay?
Ja, es war es hier, oder?
20 Uhr Dienstag.
Reicht eine? Ja.
Alles klar.
Denn, ja, es ist noch ein bisschen hin bis zum Wochenende, aber ich nähe, dass sie nochmal reingewohnt auf der Artichie.
Es waren wirklich zwei gute Events heute Abend.
Und ich wünsche allen einen erholsamen Abend.
Und ich freue mich, sie am Dienstag wieder zu sehen.
Tschüss.